Christian is with Fabi for a podcast
we don't have a podcast to Yasser right
now scheduled but we do have an
interview because Fabiano just finished
his game against the newly crowned world
champion the English Iran first of all
Fabi welcome uh to the show tell us a
bit about your approach to this
particular game well let's talk about
yesterday as well because you played
Bogdan Daniel deck the lowest rated
player in the event and he did surprise
him and got some nice Advantage at least
a practical Advantage out of the opening
did you feel that was a success and
did you miss any chances in yesterday's
game yeah I think the opening he knew
relatively well more or less like he
played a good line and he equalized
um but at some point he played a very
very bad move like it was an equal
position for pretty much the entire game
although I guess he was trying to get a
bit under pressure especially with time
and then he played Bishop page five
which is a very bad move and I responded
also with a very bad move and after
Bishop I'm probably winning if I take on
C5 it should be a winning position
but after Rooks he wanted to get nothing
and and then he played well in in time
travel so yeah yesterday was
unfortunately a big pretty big missed
chance but today
um with the black pieces against dingley
Wren we know how much residual opening
preparation he might have coming from
the world championship match what was
the strategy were you trying to surprise
him early on in the opening it felt like
you did
yeah I'm not sure he actually has
anything from the match like my
impression is that he had no ideas at
the end of the match at some point they
ran out and he he's not really like
trying very hard at the start of this
tournament maybe he's still trying to
recover some energy but yesterday he
didn't really try very hard like against
maximen today as well I played a very
very unusual line let's talk about it
um
did he surprise you at all with the
Catalan or was that something that you
were more or less excited I thought that
he could play first move C4 and I
decided to surprise him a bit by playing
what Jan played against him in the
tiebreak and there instead of D4 he
played B3
but it led to a very very dry end game
so that's why I I wasn't surprised that
he would go for the cattle on
and
so it was one of like the main things I
thought could happen today
and okay the 96 is a super rare move I
think he's faced it before against young
um
or you know it's right now you can see
all that against fruition yeah played
against him I'm not sure that might have
been a Blitz game but or maybe rap again
but it's a very rare line Ali Reza likes
it that's it's basically his line uh
computers don't like it but it's it's
not bad at all and I think I played a
novelty with Queen D7
I think that game was with Queen E8
against uh Queen 38 yeah
he was thinking a long time maybe he was
trying to recall exactly the details of
the line uh Queen E7 is a new move and
what is the main difference between the
smooth Queen D7 and queen to EA I mean
the main point of the position is that
black is worse unless you dislodge the
knight from C6 like denies is is very
dangerous
um but white lacks some development to
keep the Knight on C6 so one of the main
ideas for black is to play Bishop C5 at
some moment uh and for example Queen to
E8 has the idea
of playing Bishop C5 but avoiding Knight
E5 after Queen Southern well Queen D7 is
is still preparing Bishop C5 that's why
white plays Rook T1 so Bishop c595
and our work fc8 is um
sort of like it's it's kind of a useful
move uh the point is white can't develop
so easily without allowing uh because
Knight C3 hangs the the Knight
um Knight takes E7 blankets C5 very
quickly so this is probably probably
nothing yeah it could sound like Bishop
H6 or H6 first yeah but in usually why
he wants to maintain his Knight and so
very critical move is Knight to D2
because if white gets just like one more
move to play Knight F3 here black is in
like very serious positional trouble and
so black should play Bishop C5 the point
being that Knight E5 now uh Queen takes
D4 is as possible and then this is this
is like a very critical line
and B4 and uh rook d8 pc5 and Knight D6
um and yeah like for example the
computer I see here shows that black is
much worse with various moves but it is
objectively okay and it's very sharp
it's very risky of course because
Black's King side is damaged
um white could develop an attack but
somehow black is always in time because
at night it becomes very active once it
gets tough five so okay this was
very critical line in Bishop G5 I think
he
basically showed that he was ready to
maybe call it a day or yeah it's the
safest move it trades a lot of pieces I
thought that he would actually go for
this one
because if c5d5
um
yeah and I think like one of the moves
was Queen to E7 I think this was okay
um like I remembered I think this lines
T5 D5 and Knight to A5 allowing in D6
which was kind of possible
oh yeah yeah D6 D6 somehow is not very
good for white and
um
yeah I mean black has many approaches so
I was going to to think
in case we got here because I
didn't really check this position I just
knew that this was one of the ways for
white to get like a very slightly better
position
um and then he decided to uh I think he
he kind of thought this was interesting
for white
somebody had to put the Rook on C3 maybe
take yeah like Knight d8 Rook C3 I think
that this is basically his dream and one
of the important points is that for
example if I play Bishop B7 and Bishop
C5 just doesn't work because Queen E4
um otherwise he would have to retrieve
his Rook here and maybe I would equalize
but I mean nice if I was the first one
which came to mind and it just took a
little bit of time to
just make sure you're not blundering
anything and well just some details like
for example Rook D3 I think yeah there's
probably A5 but also I was
I was kind of reasonably I was actually
not 100 sure about this position because
he he sags a poem but he gets the C4
Square
so I was going to think after Rook D3
but I thought A5 is probably
um a clean bailout and yeah there were
probably early moves even like C6 I was
thinking I mean I I just first stop any
invasions on C6 and then chase the night
away
and um he decided to repeat after
thinking for quite a long time yeah were
you expecting him to try to continue in
any way shape or form or I was hoping I
was hoping you were hoping I was hoping
because
um like I can't really deviate here I
don't have a way I think I
um without getting a worse position or
or at least a slightly worse position
but he has some like
some ways which look interesting After
High B7 yeah and uh
it's kind of it's a little bit
disappointing I guess to make a draw
with white so early so I was hoping
maybe his uh his kind of ambition would
carry him forward a bit but
um
and okay he's a bit lower on time so I
maybe I would get a game but uh I wasn't
too surprised that he repeated because
it it does start to look a bit risky
with your knight on B1 kind of just it's
not in the game so you're you're not
really in the position to play on for
Your Balanced start to uh this
tournament we'll see you in the next
round
thank you Christian thank you fabric
question for